yoga is bad I know young white women
even older white women white women of a
certain age they love yoga but
no bueno no
um in fact a couple minutes ago when you
said speaking of people that insult
Their audience I thought that's how you
were introducing me because this insults
my audience more than any other topic
and it's really amongst Christians that
I get the most backlash from
and I have found that it is because
honestly I'm just going to come right
out and say it's because yoga is the
practice that invokes the most demons
so when you're practicing yoga
constantly you are entirely demonized
and so not only is your flesh kind of at
enmity with the truth of what yoga is
but the demons are too they don't like
to hear that